fSchon jetzt fordert der klimawandel millionen tote durch hitzewellen krankheiten und unterernährung
Werden immer mehr menschen opfer und selbst hier in europa werden wir nicht verschont in den gemäßigten breiten hat der klimawandel
auch schon bereits hunderttausende umgebracht und der co2 gehalt in der atmosphäre der steigt immer weiter
trotz der immer effektiveren anstrengungen zur reduktion der co2 emissionen die bisher kaum beachteten folgen des klimawandels
Hunger hitze krankheit und wo der klimawandel die meisten menschen umbringt jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Der sommer 2003 war die hölle und zwar hier in europa temperaturen über 40 grad celsius
Waren keine ausnahme sondern der standard und über 37 grad also über unser körper temperatur wird es gefährlich
70.000 menschen starben damals schätzungsweise und das in europa weltweit sieht es nicht anders aus aber
schlimmer und seit dem jahr 2000 macht das inzwischen
millionen tote aus dass wissenschaftliche medizin magazin the lancet veröffentlicht dazu jedes jahr ein report seinen countdown
health and climate change report der über die
gesundheitlichen folgen des klimawandels berichtete human comedy direktor des institute for human health and performance
Am university college in london
Hat an der studie mitgewirkt zitat wir spüren gerade erst die ersten auswirkungen des klimawandels
Wir müssen sowohl die symptome. Als auch die ursachen des klimawandels
Bekämpfen zitat ende und die auswirkungen sind schon jetzt dramatisch hitzewellen wie 2003 und auch
2015 sind dabei die größten risiken seit dem jahr 2000 sind
125 millionen menschen alljährlich solchen hitzewellen ausgesetzt gewesen
2040 werden es wahrscheinlich eine milliarde menschen
Jedes jahr seien die folge jedes jahr sterben millionen menschen am klimawandel
Am schlimmsten betroffen dabei die unterernährten menschen in afrika und asien ihre zahl ist seit 1990 von
398 millionen auf 422 millionen gestiegen und auch das ist eine folge des klimawandels
Die ernten gehen zurück ein grad höhere temperaturen weltweit
bedeuten zehn prozent geringere reis und 6 prozent geringere weizen ernten die wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen die an der studie
mitgearbeitet haben rechnen mit großem
hungerkatastrophen zusätzlich führen die hohen temperaturen auch zur vermehrten chronischen leiden
nierenerkrankungen diabetes nehmen zu und auch infektionskrankheiten
Breiten sich stärker aus die größte infektionsgefahr geht dabei von dengue fieber aus die überträger die
gelbfiebermücken breiten sich immer mehr über den globus aus und haben die übertragungsraten seit den 50er jahren um knapp zehn
prozent steigen lassen der klimawandel scheint immer schwerer zu stoppen zu sein die weltwetterorganisation wmo
Berichtet jetzt dass die co2 konzentration in der atmosphäre
weiter steigt obwohl der ausstoß weltweit in den letzten drei jahren nicht gestiegen ist die
Konzentration ist jetzt so hoch wie zuletzt vor drei bis fünf millionen jahren und damals lag der meeresspiegel 10 bis 20 meter
Höher grund ist zum einen natürlich dass der co2 ausstoß einfach zu hoch ist um den co2 anteil in der atmosphäre?
sinken zu lassen und zum anderen an
Wetterphänomen die aber auch in dieser starken ausprägung auf den klimawandel zurückzuführen sind el niño war mit seinen erhöhten ozean
temperaturen und dürren 2016 extrem stark durch das veränderte klima konnten ozeane und wälder
weniger co2 aufnehmen als sonst zitat die zahlen lügen nicht wir stoßen nach wie vor zu viel aus und dies muss sich ändern
das sagt der chef des un umweltprogramms unep
Erik solheim es muss also dringend
Dafür gesorgt werden dass der co2 ausstoß nicht nur stagniert sondern auch verringert wird nur so haben wir die chance die zahl der opfer
einigermaßen zu begrenzen ansonsten drohen weitere aber und abermillionen tote schauen wir also mal ganz genau auf die
koalitionsverhandlungen in berlin
Ob da der schuss gehört wurde ich bin gespannt
Wenn ihr kein video zum thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier
Ein abo aufs auge und vergesse nicht den auf die glocke ja und hier geht es weiter mit klimawandel bewiesen
skeptiker endgültig widerlegt also wenn irgendjemand noch zweifel hat ohne argumente sucht das video ist pflicht ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran